[Music]
this is my favorite hoodie
it's one i got during my studies some
more than 10 years ago
and it carries font memories from some
of the most important years of my life
our clothes reflect our mood our
character and personal taste
textiles are all around us
but we have somehow broken our long
lasting relationship with them
the way we consume clothes is highly
unsustainable in the eu we waste about
5.8 million tons of textiles
around 11 kilos per person
this waste and fast fashion pollutes our
environment and requires excessive use
of precious resources like water energy
fossil fuels
not to mention all problems coming from
the discarding of textiles
most of them
end up in incineration or landfills
in europe and even abroad
it's time that fast fashion is driven
out of fashion
that's why we put forward our pioneering
eu textile strategy by 2030
textile products placed on the eu market
should be long-lived recyclable and
recycled free of hazardous chemicals and
produced in a fair way
we can achieve that with mandatory eco
design requirements and a brand new
digital product passport for textiles
and more reuse and repair services
we want to tackle microplastics
introduce extended producer
responsibility
and stop the destruction of unsolved or
returned garments
all this won't happen without a
competitive resilient and innovative
textile sector
our fashion can become greener with deep
changes that require efforts by all of
us
let's become more conscious consumers
with fashion brands joining us in that
green transition
[Music]